hello and welcome everyone
to the active inference live stream it
is act imp stream 9.1
and it is november 24th 2020.
so welcome everyone to the act imp
stream and welcome to
team com today in the
act imp stream we will be talking about
a really interesting paper so i'm quite
excited
team com is an experiment in online team
communication
learning and practice related to active
inference
you can find us at our website our
twitter
at email our youtube or our public key
based team
and shared key based username this
is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here
and also just as far as video etiquette
for live stream
remember to mute if there's any noise in
your background raise your hand so that
we can hear from everybody on the stack
and use respectful speech behavior etc
just to quickly go through the rest of
the meetings that we'll be having for
2020. today on november 24th we're
talking about the projective
consciousness model and phenomenal
selfhood
next week in 9.2 on december 1st we're
going to be talking about the same paper
so anything that gets raised today
whether you're
participating live or watching replay
let us know about it so we can cover it
in 9.2
on december 8th and 15th in 10.1 and
10.2 we'll be discussing the paper
a variational approach to scripts and
then on december 22nd
and 29th we'll be talking about
sophisticated
effective inference and that will be
another more on the modeling
side paper to discuss cool
today in act im stream 9.1
the roadmap will be as follows we'll
start off with some introductions and
warm-up
questions and then we'll get to 9.1
we're going to be talking about the
paper called the projective
consciousness model
and phenomenal selfhood by williford at
all 2018.
and the punchline of this paper is
basically about the combination of a few
different fields
geometry cybernetics neurophenomenology
etc
and by combining these fields under the
framework of active inference
there might be something there to
understand or explain about
consciousness
so we'll go through the aims and the
claims of the authors the abstract and
the roadmap
and then at multiple points here and
throughout
we want to take time for questions so
really anyone who
raises their hand we'll just as soon as
we can
cut there because it's so interesting
what people
have come to mind during these
provocative topics
then we'll go to the author's study of
consciousness
and talk about the two lists that they
make and what those lists
do for the paper and do for their theory
and those are the functional features
and the phenomenological invariance of
consciousness
and then at the end we'll go through the
figures
and with however much time we have we'll
go into thinking about what each figure
might represent or invoke
and as stated in 9.2 we're going to be
discussing this same paper again
so save and submit any questions you
have and get in touch with us if you
want to participate
great for the introductions and warm-up
please just introduce yourself
and your location say hello and as short
of an intro as you'd like
and then pass it to somebody else who
hasn't yet spoken
so i will go first i'm daniel i'm in
california
and i'll pass it to alex
uh i hope i'm audible my name is alex
i'm
also in california uh and i will pass
this to
shannon
hey i'm shannon i would be in california
normally but i'm in south dakota
so i'll pass it to lee
hi i'm lee i'm in london and i'll pass
it to
mathis
right currently muted
okay hi i'm mathis i'm currently in
germany in oslonbrook
and i passed it to even
hello my name is ivan i'm from moscow
russia and i pass it to sasha
hi my name is sasha i'm also in
california
and i'll pass it to alex
v
thanks hi i'm alex i'm in moscow
russia and i pass it to steven
hello i'm steven i'm in toronto in
canada
cool that is everyone so great thanks
for these introductions everybody
let's do some warm-up questions and
there'll be a few of them
and anyone who would like to talk just
jump on with raising your hand
let's try to hear from everyone as well
the first question
and i'll do actually the first and the
second question together since i think
that they're very related
the first question is what interests you
about studying consciousness and the
second
question is what are some ways that we
can study
consciousness um maybe someone's a
skeptic maybe they don't think that we
can study consciousness or maybe they
have a really awesome
uh idea about how we could do that so
lee uh go ahead what's your first
thought
uh yeah so um i mean i primarily come
from the
uh phenomenological angle and um
particularly kind of neurophenomenology
really and what i'm really interested in
is agency so can the
can the models uh that come out of uh
coming out of neuroscience can they
help us to um increase our uh
our agency so for example um
if you can become reflectively aware of
simulations modal simulations that are
going on
in your system then do those become
affordances for actions that we can take
and so you
increase the scope of of agency so
that's kind of what really interests me
about this
cool thanks shannon
i love that you bring up agency right
off the bat
um something that's really interesting
for me about consciousness which i don't
study at all is when we lose our sense
of agency
like when we're in flow states if we're
making music or
i guess people get in flow states if
they really like exercising
and we're completely immersed in the
experiment experience
but not consciously aware or we don't
have the same kind of intentionality
that we do as if maybe we're we're like
writing down
a math problem or trying to speak over a
live stream and
and thinking very carefully about each
of our words and
i guess just the phenomenal quality of
those two types of experience
is really interesting to me i agree
and it's part of this what is
consciousness question and what is the
role of awareness
so when we're really paying attention to
doing a task with our hands
when we're really paying attention to
balancing on a beam or something like
that
are we truly at our most self-aware at
that moment
or are we at our least self-aware or in
which ways are we self-aware we're not
thinking about our biographical history
per se but in another sense we're the
most embodied and an active
sort of circuit for action so where is
that going to fit in with active
inference and with this idea that we are
embodied in an environment so what is
yeah really more experiential of the
self
doing something that might take up your
whole body or bring your full attention
to bear or doing something that asks you
to write a personal statement
something like an autobiographical or
narrative self
cool if anyone else wants to go on the
first two those are good questions
or the last question here is just like
what is another
theory or framework for consciousness
that you know of or have heard about
doesn't need to be your
theory to um support or deny here just
like what is something
else that is in the space of this paper
and then what's just something that you
liked about it or found absent from that
model
so all just starts with something that i
found missing from a lot of models and i
really want to know where agency
and where a lot of other topics fit into
play here is it's often a little unclear
whether consciousness
is something that reaches back into the
system and intervenes
or whether it's something that's just
purely epi phenomenal
or kind of um just there can be
awareness but awareness may not have
causal power
so is consciousness something that's
just getting spun off to the side
and produced but not reaching back into
the system
or is it something that's actually
essential potentially even in an
evolutionary or adaptive context
for maintaining coherent behavior
stephen
yeah i'm i'm interested in in this
question of self-consciousness
that seems to be and i like just the
idea of general consciousness being
thought about because i think in
psychology this idea of the self
and the idea of the individual has
become so dominant and the idea of
broader consciousness was kind of
left 100 years ago for the philosophers
to deal with so this idea of i have a
self and i have this
um idea of a psychology and this
perspective on the psychology
has become kind of all-encompassing but
now
this ability to bring consciousness in
more broadly
sort of dissolves a lot of those
problems because it it kind of stuck
psychology at this single scale of
analysis
um so that's one of the things i think
that um
is quite exciting by all of this
cool sasha
um one thing that i i find missing i
feel like a broken record sometimes
um is the developmental side of
consciousness
um and even if we're thinking about
humans you know our favorite species
uh how does consciousness develop across
a lifetime
and what are the different uh stages or
versions of consciousness that we pass
through um and is there a sort of a
developmental trajectory because um
i tend to think it's not like flipping a
light switch
like it's not that we are born and we're
immediately plugged into
this um same consciousness that we're
experiencing today
so um yeah that's kind of what i would
like to see from
a consciousness model is different
levels or
versions of it that we can start to
describe like much like the flow state
or
um sleep cool shannon
yeah i like both of those um points that
stephen and sasha brought up
and not just how does our our personal
consciousness develop over time but how
does our
consciousness like our group
consciousness um develop
so like as an infant a lot of your
conscious experience is really coupled
with
the mother or the caregiver and
like slowly you might develop a sense of
of yourself
as an individual separate from that
caregiver
but also when we gather in groups you
know when we gather at concerts or
we gather at protests or in events where
we're
a mix of explicitly or implicitly
interacting with each other
we start to behave like like one group
and in some sense we start to really
feel
like one group rather than like just
myself in a room full of other people
yep cool and something in the ant
literature
people have wondered about is the nest
mate conscious is just
the colony conscious but not the nest
mate then what is really
happening with this transition from
individual to group
and the development of that also
interesting the formation of group is it
kind of like how many sand grains make a
heap
you know once there's three people it's
a collective consciousness or do they
have to be doing contact improv or do
they have to be
rhythmically synchronized what are those
dynamics what might be metrics
what might be things that we could come
to the table and agree on
as far as measurements are concerned so
that we could kind of move the needle
forward in research
or is this a question that because of
its maybe fundamental
difficulty in measurement is it a
question that's sort of forever
going to be in the speculative domain i
think that the authors of this paper
would suggest that
scientific study of consciousness is
meritous
and that there's value in approaching
with even a mathematical
bent approaching how we could study
consciousness
though it's by no means obvious that
mathematics is the way that we're going
to
express the language or the structure of
consciousness
especially when we start to think about
all these different dimensions like
group versus individual and what you
know who is individual
we were never individuals that type of
thinking what does the brain region know
that the neuron doesn't and the brain
know that the region doesn't
all these questions are gonna come into
play and a lot of the
neuro and social parts are gonna get a
little bit
um not swept under the rug here but this
paper
is clearly a little bit more on the cut
and dry
projective geometry side and there's a
lot of discussion of neurophenomenology
but you don't see any pictures of cells
you don't see any actual details of
neural mechanisms it's just assume well
you could wrap mechanisms and mechanisms
kind of close to the end to get this
type of a systems behavior
and so we'll get a little bit more into
it so at any point of course people are
welcome to
raise their hand we'll just try to
immediately whatever springs to mind in
a relevant moment so no worries about
these prompts let's talk about the paper
which is the projective consciousness
model and phenomenal selfhood
by williford at all in december 2018
in frontiers in psychology theoretical
and philosophical psychology
the aims and the claims of the paper are
basically as such
they ask can we describe this integrated
multimodal and centered spatial
structure of conscious experience in a
rigorous way
and can we give a good account of why it
should be thus organized
here we answer both questions in the
affirmative great
big if true let's see these be answered
overall
the pcm delivers an account of the
phenomenologically available
generic structure of consciousness and
that speaks to steven's point about the
general consciousness
and shows how consciousness allows
organisms to integrate multimodal
sensory information memory
and emotion in order to control behavior
enhance resilience
optimize preference satisfaction and
minimize predictive error in efficient
manner
and this is again to my earlier point
about does consciousness
get spun off of the system or does it
reach back in so does
consciousness control behavior and
enhance resilience
or is that systems with controlled
behavior and enhanced properties like
resilience
do those systems spiral off
consciousness as an observer
that's vague here but the way that we
phrase these sentences
is essential it's like active versus
passive mistakes were made versus i made
a mistake versus you made a mistake
pretty different and the non-uh jargony
way
might be to ask how can we apply active
inference as this unifying framework
to the study of consciousness in all of
its unified
coherent mysterious dynamic and profound
facets
and we'll see when they get to the
functional features and the
phenomenological invariants
which aspects of consciousness they
think are sort of
the key features to explain and really
integrate across
into one common framework so that's what
we hope to be
getting at today even though this paper
is not
the whole citation network we're
definitely going to be exploring a lot
of the key ideas
and questions about how and where active
inference and the free energy principle
could link back to consciousness so
here's the abstract briefly
they write we summarize our recently
introduced projective consciousness
model pcm which is rudroff at all 2017
and relate it to outstanding conceptual
issues in the theory of consciousness
the projective consciousness model
combines a projective geometrical model
of the
perspectival that means from a
perspective phenomenological that means
what's experienced
structure of the field of consciousness
with a variational free energy
minimization model of active inference
comma yielding an account of the
cybernetic that means goal seeking
function of consciousness viz the
modulation of the field's cognitive
thought processes and affective like how
it feels emotions
dynamics for the effective control of
embody agents
another plus one for affective and
effective in the same
sentence abstract part two the
geometrical
and active inference components are
linked via the concept of projective
transformation so we'll definitely have
a slide where we look at what a
projective transformation is
which is crucial to understanding how
conscious organisms integrate
perception emotion memory reasoning and
perspectival imagination in order to
control
behavior enhance resilience and optimize
preference satisfaction
the pcm makes substantiative empirical
predictions
and fits well into a neural
computationalist framework
it also helps us to account for aspects
of subjective character that are
sometimes ignored or conflated
pre-reflective self-consciousness the
first-person point of view
the sense of mindness or of ownership
and of social self-conscious so maybe we
will get to some of these social topics
and they close by saying that we argue
that the pcm though still in development
offers the most complete theory to date
of what thomas metzinger has called
phenomenal selfhood so that's combining
this phenomenology
component with a selfhood element any
thoughts on the abstract or we can move
forward
bring them up during the roadmap so the
abstract is just the header of the paper
it's kind of like the metadata for the
in-group and out-group discussion
the roadmap is how they're actually
going to implement these kinds of claims
that are suggested
in the introduction in the abstract so
first with a more formal introduction
to the topics they discussed in the
abstract
and then they went straight to
methodology which i think is very
important especially when discussing
something that's abstract like this
then they talk about the
phenomenological invariance and the
functional features of consciousness
which we'll go through on separate
slides
and specifically they talk about these
invariants in terms of a projective
geometry feature of the pcm
they talk about the functions and then
talk about how the pcm
links the functional features of
consciousness within an active inference
and a cybernetics
framework so they're taking some of the
invariants combining them with
projective geometry
they're taking some of the features and
combining that with cybernetics uh
in the sense of active inference as a
modern phrasing of cybernetics
and free energy minimization as an
optimization process and they're kind of
connecting
experience cybernetics projective
geometry all these different things
together
and asking whether it makes sense they
then have all their four figures
which we'll go through today that range
from sort of sketch-like accounts
of psychological phenomena to some early
solutions to otherwise challenging ideas
like illusions necrocube and then they
sketch out
a few different representations and
simulations that they
run or ran elsewhere they then return to
this question of the hard problem
representationalism and phenomenal
selfhood so the hard problem
is the hard problem of consciousness
attributed to chalmers and others
that relates to basically where the
rubber hits the road how does
consciousness arise or what is it i
think there's many hard problems
and who knows which ones we think are
easy but actually are hard the point is
they're going to come at that nexus from
a computational and a functional angle
then they talk about representationalism
in the pcm
and i feel like representationalism
we've heard about a bunch
on active stream with a bayesian
structural representationalism
and now we're going to come at it from a
different angle from a geometric and a
cybernetic angle
they then talk about how the pcm is
linked to subjective character
as well as phenomenal selfhood which is
clearly one of the things that they're
out to describe
and then they conclude so they're gonna
go
from taking a few different threads of
phenomenological
neuro research and tie that with some
more mechanism agnostic control theory
approaches
like cybernetics active inference and
optimization approaches like free energy
minimization
they're going to bring in this
projective consciousness uh projective
geometry bit
to tie it all together and then we get
to the conclusions and also some of
their thoughts on where to go next
so let's just pause there i've written
out a few
questions but does anyone just have a
thought or
a question or when they read the paper
like what was the first
thought was there something that
resonated a lot
was there something that seemed
ill-defined or you would have defined it
a different way
or just something you were curious about
stephen well one thing i thought was
interesting was this idea of
perspectival
consciousness so this idea that
when you're consciously taking a
perspective on your situation
um which you normally might think of as
c
in it but it could be some sort of
embodied sense
so i think that was kind of important
and there
and how that differs from maybe the
unconscious
um dynamics that are just going on
that they don't necessarily deal with so
it's somehow sitting
i don't know sitting on top or sitting
alongside it but there's
somehow this perspectival piece that
somehow kicks in
yeah and we often think about vision
in talking about how active inference is
to be differentiated from let's just say
a sensory relay model where you know
photons come in
your brain categorizes them and makes an
image and then you act
and here it's like it's a generative
model of the world that you're
experiencing that's why there's color
and good resolution around the edges and
no blind spot
and then it's like well then why do we
see what appears to be coming from our
eyes or
from a position that's right there and
that's where we're going to come back to
with a lot of these questions about the
projection itself
and why we appear to be situated lee
sorry yeah i don't know if it's relevant
but um i was just thinking about
so the the discovery of perspective uh
you know back in the in the
enlightenment and i was thinking well
obviously you know if this is a sort of
a more generic theory of consciousness
then
i was wondering if it connected perhaps
to metzinger's idea of transparent
states
so that uh you know the projected
geometry would have always been there
but they would have been transparent and
somehow
you know in the process of the discovery
of perspective uh it became something
that we were able to pay
attention to more more consciously
anyway just a thought
cool idea let me actually unpack that
first what would you describe as the
transparent state because i don't know
of that terminology specifically what is
a transparent
state here so i think in mexico's model
so transparent states would be
those states that we are that we view
the world through
so we then we're in a stable we don't
know that we're having a particular
state whereas
he he contrasted to us a meta i think
really so an opaque state would be
a state where we where we understand
that it's as
a sensory state if you know what i mean
cool the transparent state it's kind of
like what is water
the water we swim in it's like the water
is transparent so when you look out in
all directions
it's not being seen specifically yeah
like you're looking through it you're
looking through it but you're not able
to actually observe it as a state of
of your as a state an embodied state
that you're having if you see what i
mean
yeah just to unpack this one bit for
steven um
it's kind of like without a theory of
error you could just look forever and
you could just have
any model could replace this idea about
what fills up space
then there's this chemical theory of air
and there have been various chemical
theories of
air and whether there's four types of
things they mix or whether it's protons
and neutrons and different ratios and
things like that
and then once you have a theory of air
you could ask things like what if i
compressed all of the quote invisible
stuff in this room and all of a sudden
it looks like blue or something it's
like
whoa it kind of is there there's unique
experiments there's unique predictions
i'm taking something that was
transparent in the niche that actually
was real ontologically real and then
through attention and awareness and
affordances we're able to now like
look at it so we've developed projective
geometry
and it's like whoa what if it really
were projective geometry all along but
then now with the projective geometric
tools
we're coming back to experience that and
it's actually something that steven and
i were talking about just this weekend
with
a little bit like what people's
experiences of perspective have been in
the past
um because there is those sometimes
funny pictures
um at least comical sometimes where it's
like a person's face and it looks like
it's from
almost a cubist angle but it's like a
renaissance painting and
there's probably so much to say from an
art history perspective about the
evolution and the development
of perspective but at the very least it
seems like people
throughout time have been differentially
excited by different types of
representations of perspective
people weren't doing photo realistic
charcoal drawings
in a different era even if they necess
could have had the um
technologies to do so so something is
happening there with perspective and how
it's
changing the way that we interact with
the visual world cubism of course was
shocking
and uh when it came out and so now where
are we with perspective
um there's a lot to say about that
stephen
yeah i mean one of the things that's
interesting with like imagined
feelings in space is that they can be
kind of transparent so if you like
what's the energy of someone or if i
imagine the energies of people
around me it's like a quality those
qualities they don't
like if you imagine something in space
it doesn't become completely opaque it's
not like you can't see that you're in
the room anymore
you know so even if you're on stage as
an actor and you imagine that you're in
a scene
with a king and it's an empty stage and
you start to imagine the whole stage you
it's still slightly transparent in
relation to the physical
perceptive conscious physical space if
that makes sense so those two things are
kind of
interplaying yep but yeah and to bring
that to the affordances in the field of
affordances field of consciousness it's
like
the generative model isn't just of what
the video camera
would see if it were next to your head
the generative model is actually
generating
this field of action that's scaled
geometrically so that things that are
closer to you and better within reach
are seemingly at hand and things that
are distant are seemingly distant and
one example that steve and i were
talking about was like
there might be an object on the other
side of my monitor that i'd have to kind
of go around
to reach and just right with a quick
judgment
it feels like something on the other
side of my monitor is actually further
away
than something that might be linearly
closer um or further away sorry but like
i can reach it directly just by reaching
my hand over i can reach two feet over
with my arm just grab
it but the 18 inches linearly to the
monitor i have to end up doing a 36 inch
route so it feels longer away
so even within our at hand concepts and
the way that we talk about
what is accessible or what is um
relevant
these all have to do with the grasping
and the comprehending and the action
distortion of a space so there's really
a lot here about the perspectives that
we take
and if we say there's one perspective
and it's mine there's one perspective
and it's
my cultures or is it hey we're all at
this party and we're all gonna have
different perspectives of this party
okay which perspectives can hang which
ones can't those are the kinds of
discussions that you get to there
instead of is it right wrong the way i'm
seeing it because you know not
everyone's to see the party like you see
it because no one's head
is overlapping with your perception
because everyone's affordances and
location are different for example
sasha yeah i really appreciated in this
paper um a kind of connection
um uh we're always talking about on this
stream
um between uh you know taking in
information and
acting um and so it's this feedback loop
of two things
and i really like this converting
uh thinking about our space into
thinking about the space of affordances
so that it's not just a you know a blank
slate of information that
uh you could access or not but it's
really what you
are able to do with that information and
how you're going to act on it
so i yeah i just thought that was a
really nice connection and
fits in very well with what we're
talking about and kind of
builds up this um similar theme of
how you're going to connect action and
perception
cool and just one other example that
that kind of
uh made me think about is like when i'm
dissecting an insect
under a microscope um it's very small
movements
of the fingers but it in the field of
vision of a microscope will swing the
forceps like you know 30 degrees so
it'll be a a radical motion
under the microscope but it has the
exact same embodiment
feel as like swinging one's arm almost
as if what matters is
how much i'm seeing my body move within
a visual field
and how radical of an affordance it is
like flailing my arm versus a more
fine-tuned movement
but a fine-tuned movement with the arm
is like one inch but that's represented
by a certain number of degrees
and that ends up being like visually
almost the same number of degrees
that i can move the forceps so even
though it's at a different spatial scale
because the attention and the
affordances are down at that scale
and i have the visual ability the umvelt
to perceive at that smaller scale which
couldn't be seen if it were the naked
eye
it takes on a feeling like it's in the
regular vision regular body world
and then also the uh forceps don't have
nerves but they're
sensitized so there's a lot to say and
think about there
um a few questions that i just wrote
down here just
like these are of course perennial
questions
they're not going to be answered in a
couple minutes but
what's exciting about studying
consciousness what do we
agree on what do people agree on what do
people disagree on and then
also what do people agree is unknown
what are the known unknowns where might
there be unknown unknowns
and then also to always return to what
is
active inference doing here what could
it do here what could some other
theory do here what do you think shannon
yeah so your story about the forceps and
the microscope reminded me of
the first example of like extended
consciousness
that i learned about and in a philosophy
of mind class in undergrad
and our professor was talking about
divers um who are they're not actually
diving they're in a room
and they're controlling a camera like on
a little submarine
that's underwater and they start to
feel like they are the submarine
so much so that their body's actually
responding
to the the pressure differences that
they would experience if they were
diving so if the submarine comes up
very fast they'll actually ex feel like
they're experiencing the bends
that would happen if they were a diver
coming up so fast i don't know if this
is a true
um story i've never looked it up but
it's
very intriguing that your consciousness
can be can be so extended that you end
up having these embodied effects that
you
perhaps could empirically measure if you
if you were if you had some sensors on
on these people as they were
experiencing these extended conscious
moments
cool lee um i was just going to ask
shannon um
do you know whether that depends on
whether the uh people
controlling the remote sub were have
previously dived as well so they kind of
got the
you know the embodied experience as part
of their model
i think for that for specifically the
bends it would or maybe they would have
to know about
the bends because that's a very specific
thing that doesn't happen to your body
in any other case
yeah one thing that makes me think of is
like uh
the drop in a techno song when
everything's building and the tension's
building but that's actually a cultural
regime of affordance
and different sub-genres of electronica
or different people who are
aren't familiar with electronica they
might get chills going down their spine
it's like oh this is the sickest drop
ever
but somebody else might just not be
tuned into that regime of attention
and therefore it's like okay wait what
happened why is it just why did the
drums stop something like that so
similarly it's like the diver
if they're part of this deep generative
model and then they're they're emulating
it or they're simulating it somehow
um this diving then they may have a
deeply learned
reflex about changing their blood
pressure let's just you know
go with star experiment being vaguely
you know feeling true
just ish that you could if you're doing
a first-person shooter
immersive video game your heart is going
to start pounding not because you need
increased blood flow that's a
psychological response
so trained psychological responses in
increasingly immersive environments like
ar
and vr will generate physiological
responses
and that is actually part of the thrill
that was i mean there's so
much happening here and it doesn't
really go into the ar vr here but like
what if we unprojected our projective
geometry what
would happen or what about these uh sort
of alice in wonderland type
simulators for the ar and the vr where
you re you reach towards something but
your arm moves twice as fast
or you reach towards something and your
arm doesn't move you crash into stuff
and it just feels like you're like super
disoriented
or the glasses are flipped all of these
transformations
are just super deep interventions
into the structure of sense and action
so
there's a lot that is now possible here
with how we can on the fly
remap these things in 1920 the cubist
could
put a light on one side of the cube and
draw it and then halfway through the
drawing move the light and get a
different perspective and that was kind
of cool like a mashup of perspectives
in one two-dimensional plane but now you
could be experiencing like
a lot more stuff happening and the cube
could be mutating it could be a
hypercube and stuff like that
it's kind of next level with respect to
our geometry
and how it relates to our sense in
action
any other thoughts or questions here
before we go to the functional
features just think of them as they come
up
so the authors highlight four functional
features
of consciousness which are global
optimization and resilience
global availability motivation of action
and modulation of attention
and simulation enhancement so their
goals are basically these are the things
that they say
notice that it's very
mechanism-independent it doesn't say you
got to have neurons you need glia
it doesn't say it has to be at this time
scale these are all like things that you
might say about
a cybernetic system a control theory
action perception
system so these features are the
abstract
functional features of consciousness
which through neurophenomenology will
get brought into the brain
perhaps but just at the functional level
these are the functions of consciousness
and they write we claim that the overall
function of consciousness
again is it that consciousness is
getting spun off by systems that have
these functions
or is consciousness literally the
function that maps back into the system
and gives these features um
presence in the world we claim that the
overall
function of consciousness is to address
a general cybernetic problem or problem
of control
consciousness enables again ambiguous a
situated organism
with multiple sensory channels to
navigate its environment and satisfy its
biological and derived needs efficiently
this entails minimizing and predictive
this entails minimizing
predictively erroneous representations
of the world
and maximizing preference satisfaction a
good model of consciousness
must be able to explain how this is
accomplished the pcm thus emphasizes the
following
interrelated functional features of
consciousness so
ask yourself if there was a robot that
could do intermodal
sensory things and memory and it was
doing counter factual simulations and it
had motivated looking action
and modulation of attention global
availability of some variables or some
processes and
it was resilient within some resilience
of course we're not resilient to getting
hit with a hammer on the head
we are resilient to you know a train
coming at us from
a mile away but not an inch away i mean
it's always going to be about
where you draw the bounds oh i mean
that's out of bounds
you don't need to be resilient to that
kind of an insult to this drug but to
this molecule you are
so i would just ask if we had a robot
that had some of these features
would we include it in the conscious
club or
would dennit include it in the club no
would a pan psychist yeah they might say
well it's something it's like to be that
robot
but where are we really getting if we
just say it's something it's like
to be this robot and this thermometer
and this networking system well if the
only way we can ask it is the exact same
affordances that we as observers have
today
like measuring electromagnetic
frequencies or something like that
then aren't we going to be debating
these things forever
because no one really disagrees that
these things all appear to happen
for systems that we think are complex
goal directed systems like humans and
cats and things like that
but isn't the question about what else
we're going to do
beyond this so hopefully that's where
the projective geometry
it's kind of like that's the uh hook
that they hang their coat on
so to speak they're gonna bring it all
to projective geometry
and they're gonna say this is what
explains all these functional features
and the invariants which we'll get to in
a second
and it makes some other predictions that
would be unique and testable
so they're going to say yeah there's
probably a lot of ways that theories of
consciousness could explain these
features
like attention schema theory or the
global workspace theory or
integrated information theory all these
different frameworks for consciousness
but we're going to take these things and
we're going to go in a new direction by
talking about the projective geometry
so what supports in their eyes
the need for not just a quantitative or
a formalized framework but also
specifically the projective geometry
and for them it's about these
phenomenological invariants
so it's kind of like universal basic
income it's like it's universal
you know these are invariant what part
of that don't you get so these are the
things that
generalized systems of consciousness you
could debate with them whether
these systems that they're talking about
are the right ones or whatever but
these are the invariant features of
experience and phenomenology
and they have them as relational
phenomenal intentionality which is that
all experience and all consciousness
is about relations especially between
one and another system like internal and
external relationship even though as
we're gonna kind of see it's a little
bit trippier than that but
basically it's about the relation of
like the i to
not i it's like i thou i i you these
kinds of things
there's a situated 3d spatiality
and that means that you're starting
you're in a situated spot you're not
just
everywhere experiencing a 3d simulation
but it's always perceived as from a
situated spot
in spatial dimensions three of them and
then through time three and four there's
this multimodal synchronic integration
which is
in a snapshot it's multimodal and then
four is through time
everything is happening so this is kind
of capturing through space or through
senses and then through time
saying yep you're at a concert and
there's the light and the sound and
things bumping into you all of that is
happening in this integrated way you
don't just experience
those separately um at the very least
the illusion
appears to cover integration across
senses which are qualitatively different
like a chemical is different than a
photon from the sun
and then there's this temporal
integration through time which is kind
of related to the
perceived event durations uh there's
messages that can be flashed on a screen
or sounds that can be outside of your uh
awareness but there's also ones that can
be
within your awareness at a certain
duration of time
so if it flashes for a second it's able
to be at a time scale that's integrated
into consciousness
um there might be time scales that
influence you below that
but it doesn't become aware so like
that's kind of conscious and
subconscious
but it's dealing with that um a little
bit uh
blurry about whether consciousness is
just the whole neurosystem
and anything that gets integrated into
the nervous system through time is
considered to be temporarily integrated
or is it that there's experiences that
actually play out over certain time
scales that we experience
and then lastly kind of related to one
is this subjective character
which is that it's about the subject and
one
and five are very similar but in fact
they hold that
two through five are all implicated in
one
okay so they have the functional
features it's pretty abstract and
cybernetic
and then they're like okay what are the
invariants
almost the axioms that we want to be
building from
that we want our theory to be able to
address
and then they're they laid them all out
one through five and then they're like
yep
turns out that two through five all
collapse back on to one so
really one is the part we need to
explain
in how they've set up the problem so
it's relational it's about the
relationship between
the agent and the world it's phenomenal
it's based upon experience
and it deals with intentionality and
that is gonna bring in
agency affordances all these kinds of
things that have come into play
okay any thoughts on the invariance or
the functional
features of consciousness because in a
sense that's what's
that's what frames the paper and it's
what frames the discussion the kinds of
answers they're going to come to is
these are their checklist for how
they'll know they'll succeed
or this is the recipe these are the
ingredients this is like what they're
cooking with
for the paper so if anyone thinks of it
they can raise their hand
i just want to clarify that because it's
like you could think about
this stuff all day but at least for a
journal club it's like what did the
authors actually specify to do did they
answer something that
um yeah so stephen
um yeah i suppose also coming back to
what lee was saying about
um perceiving things in terms of
our cognition in relation to our history
i
when we started getting into perspective
painting and thinking about things that
way
you get this sense of how much is it
about
us constructing
cognition as a cultural
way of being how much are we actually
constructing
this relational phenomenal
intentionality
culturally and that then because in
indigenous cultures you see they
think a lot more about shape-shifting
and
the land being much more fluid and
unfolded
um whereas we tend to have it much more
linear
and structured and straight edged
so there's there's some question there
about
how much this consciousness becomes like
a construct
that we actually put on the world yeah
one um researcher who's done a lot there
is the professor tanya lerman and
collaborators at stanford
and she studies um like hearing voices
in various
uh cultures and so what is the
difference between a society that says
hey the voices that you hear
are your ancestors they're telling you
cool stuff or
it's a molecular thing and it's all
random
or it's bad voices that are actually
getting into your head
that is going to be shading the
experience of the people experiencing
voices and so when we're talking about
consciousness
what if one society they tell everyone
and multi-generations it's completely
baked into their culture it's like yeah
it's an illusion you know
dennitopia everybody it's an illusion
and just the ideas that come to your
head they're literally defined by being
illusory
and you're basically just in this
perpetual auto gaslighting scenario just
don't worry about the policies we're
pushing on you just go with it
and then another culture says actually
the spark of awareness is
what should be followed even if it
appears to disassociate from social
norms
that's going to be a different outcome
and so all of those different cultures
could contain
individuals that are 100 convinced that
they're right so
being right isn't the same thing or
thinking you're right isn't the same
thing as having an answer to the
consciousness question
and yeah there's a lot of implications
with how we actually are constructing
our world and our perspective so that is
very related to lee's point i think
he's frozen for a second but yeah i
agree that was a really good point about
how
um it's like we're in feedback we're
doing niche modification for how we
perceive and
what affordances we have in the
consciousness space if you train up
people
in a insight meditation tradition since
they're children or something they're
gonna have affordances
in their consciousness uh it's another
framework good or bad
layer on top of that with a judgment but
they're depending on what
people are taught about their
consciousness growing up that is going
to
color their experience and what
affordances what trajectories they take
later on um so very interesting stuff
and i wonder like what the authors think
about that or
how they conceptualize these issues so
just to
cover this projective geometry bit
because they write
the concept of 4d four-dimensional
projective transformation
is central to the model as it yields an
account of the link between perception
imagination and multi-point of view
action planning so they're going to try
to link some of the cool stuff like
we've talked about in this action
perception loop we've asked where is
imagination
where is um imagination and speculation
and all these different things that we
appear or experience engaging in and
then also
how do we square the circle with the
fact that we're so situated in our
affordances
yet we can also imagine things that are
seemingly
uh related to our affordances like a
city's grid it doesn't seem like it's
tied directly to my affordances of
course in a traveling sense
it is but not like it doesn't depend on
where i'm sitting in my building in a
different city
so geometry is about um
the shape and the size of things whereas
topology is about how they're connected
so in topology we talk a lot about nodes
and edges and about connectedness
and structure whereas in geometry
structures related to angles and sides
and
edges and things like that and euclidean
geometry
is kind of like linear algebra is a
specific
uh case of geometry where certain
prerequisites are true like parallel
lines don't intersect and the angles of
a triangle are 180 degrees
there are non-euclidean geometries just
like there are non-linear models
and non-euclidean geometries which is
kind of like the out group
to the exclusion of euclidean so it
includes a vast number of
esoteric geometries and the way that you
can move from some geometries to other
geometries
is through a projection and that
projection is called
a map so it's kind of like seeing the
map that's in front of you it's like
it's a map
it maps your representation onto the
territory so this is like a map that
maps
one territory onto a different territory
or one geometric projection
of a territory onto another so you could
map between
two different kinds of maps of the world
you can map between a flat one
and a spherical one with certain
distortions taken along and things like
that
but the key mathematical features are
that in the euclidean paradigm
there aren't special points um there
aren't points at infinity
it just is like a vast plane that
doesn't end there's no horizon there
might be a
angle of vision that you can't resolve
below but there isn't a horizon
and a flat plane and then the art the
origin is arbitrary in that
every point you choose you could just
say oh well this is you know zero zero
zero and the
local neighborhood is exactly the same
here as it is everywhere else it's all
square contrast it with non-euclidean
geometries which are like
you can imagine though there are many
non-euclidean types
have features that include things like
special points
or points at infinity like there is a
ring of points at infinity and they're
all equally infinite far away
there can be horizons there's
non-arbitrary origins
all this kind of stuff and they're
basically going to write
the perspectival phenomenal space so our
perspective of what we're experiencing
in a geometric understanding allows us
to locate ourselves and navigate in an
ambient space that is nevertheless
essentially euclidean so you can be
in a 90 degree room but you can be
having this like wacky distorted
hyperbolic experience
of this 90 degree room and kind of
seamlessly integrating across that even
if there's a bunch of cubes or connected
you can climb through it you can
navigate in this euclidean world
and measure the angles they're 90
degrees it's all euclidean
but your perception is still going to
have this distorted effect where things
closer to you
are seemingly different than things
further from you and that means that the
angles
as you look at them unless you're in a
very specific position
will not look like 90 degrees look
around the room you're in even the
corners don't look like 90 degrees
and they basically say because um the
euclidean space has no privilege points
no points at infinity no horizon no
non-arbitrary origin
it very strongly suggests that a
non-euclidean frame must be operating
with a help of sensory motor
calibrations to preserve the sense of
invariance of objects across the
multiple perspectives adopted and relate
the situated organism to the ambient
euclidean space
it's like put your hand on a 90 degree
angle you can pretty much feel from
proprioception it's 90 degrees you look
down it's not 90 degrees
feels normal everything's chill because
we're experiencing this distortion of
the euclidean space
okay any thoughts on the projective
geometry
or about geometry or where would
geometry fit into a consciousness model
i just concur with them that there's
some functional
attributes that would point towards
non-euclidean spaces but then
every time like wait what and the how
with geometry just
how is it giving us experience again i
guess that's sort of the uh
the question but uh yeah sasha
um yeah i also thought this was really
trippy um i really liked
uh the 9.0 kind of pre
uh pre-digestion of this uh topic
so i found that really helpful um
yeah i think this is kind of trying to
walk us through
um the possible you know points of view
on consciousness that um not only does
each individual have a different
perspective
um necessarily in euclidean space um
like we're all
seeing it from different locations let's
say
but that even the the mapping is
different between individuals
onto our own non-euclidean
you know projection of uh experience and
so
i think that's that's kind of many steps
to walk through
to recognize how different um
we see the world and how we can define
this word perspective
so i think that is really uh an
important aspect of
understanding consciousness is uh where
individual
perspective is baked into the whole
process yep
and it makes me think about like um let
me see it through
your perspective or do you see it how i
see it so we have visual metaphors for
alignment and then we have put
you know walk a mile in someone else's
shoes or put yourself in their shoes
those are embodied and active
metaphors of understanding what else
someone's experience is like
and then what we're saying here is um
somehow
we should integrate that how you see it
and how you walk it
together so that your perspective is
based upon
both how you see it and the shoes that
you're walking in so your
actual embedded extended body
and how you walk in those shoes and
there's people for whom they can't
walk a mile in any shoes so what are
other metaphors that help us go beyond
just
simple walking to really understand that
more generally we're talking about like
perception and action and that because
perception and action are linked in
us in fact perspectively linked in us
it's also that way in someone else's so
it's not just about coming to agreement
with what they
think or believe or state they believe
nor is it about specifically reenacting
their action sequences which we wouldn't
either be able to do
or wouldn't even have the same
perspective on them as they do
how are we going to collaborate and so
there's like a lot of
interesting stuff and i would hope that
this provides a little bit more
structure to sometimes discussions about
everything from issues people disagree
on to accessibility
how could we whether we um bring in
projective geometry or not how can we
just
start with the idea that everyone is
going to have a unique perspective
and then work for something collective
rather than
get to this point where it's like well
we disagree okay well now what
um yeah alex go ahead uh
yeah i just wanted to say this this
brings up
uh it it reminds me of general
relativity in a way
um like conscious is some sort of uh
fundamental it's a
if two folks are in different
perspectives uh
and they can observe the order of events
occurring in different ways
are in if they can uh
observe events uh occurring out of order
based on their perspective and
a third remote
thing that they're looking at uh
maybe consciousness is the way of uh
stealth observant uh of a larger system
when uh the system is
essentially a manifold uh
the consciousness is the uh
recognition of relativity in actual
space
right and this projective geometry seems
to
kind of be getting there if we are
unable to observe the entire world and
we're only able to observe from our
perspective
consciousness is the recognition that
that is an
invariant across space and other
agents uh should have the same
uh i don't know phenomena i apologize
for
uh terminology i mostly oh that's that's
awesome
i i i really like this you said the
recognition of general
relativity is consciousness and so in
euclidean space
it's like the invariant is angle's going
to sum to 360
and this is going to work this way and
the parallel okay so those are
geometrical invariants
but because the world is so
quintessentially perspectival
and embedded and inactive actually the
invariant
is this relationship of um action and
perception
and that you move in a apparently
non-euclidean space
because the invariant is actually like
the locus
of what is generating awareness is um
consciousness
and then the two examples that came into
mind are first off you hear a noise with
each ear
at a different um time and you hear your
you know in
photons probably hit lights at your eyes
at different times but also they see
different things
but you get a monocular perception from
two different eyes
and you know but you can push one eye
you can violate an expectation and
you can see two images but basically
when it works it's binocular
and then i was thinking of a concert
where like the bass is on one side and
the treble speakers are on the other
and then it's like the group they're
actually hearing the events in a
different order
one person hears one note before the
other one and vice versa
but especially locally that doesn't mean
it's incoherent
so what is happening there that's kind
of this group consciousness question and
just thanks for bringing it to the
general relativity
level because also with the general
relativity
um innovation it was a movement from
a cartesian newtonian euclidean all
these things
um movement towards like yeah maybe
gravity isn't like a nonlinear force
operating on a euclidean
field but rather it is a non-euclidean
distortion
of another thing and so there's really a
lot to say there and then also there's
like a lot of inroads to quantum and
consciousness
whether it's uh hemorrhoids in penrose
and about the work on microtubules or
whether it's just other more broader
physics grounded theories there's so
much there about
where quantum itself might fit in so a
lot of points of contact there with
non-euclidean geometry
perspective and um and then the fact
that we
don't overlap with any other system in
terms of our
perspective and so then how do we take
that and it's like
well just like you can build a computer
in a world of general relativity
can't we design information and sense
making and attention systems that work
in a world where people have different
perspectives i'd hope so stephen
yeah i like this like really broadening
the idea
of relationships because i think what's
really helpful with this diagram is it
and talking about the map as a way of
projecting between types of spaces
rather than this idea of projection as
representations in the mind being
projected on the world
which it's kind of a slight danger with
that
language you know because it gets used
in that
in that representational way if it's
somehow
the way that we engage a type of spatial
arrangement
almost bringing in spatial cognition
work but
bringing it much more into the body um
and i think this relates maybe some of
the work with harry heft
he does some really interesting work in
the world of spatial cognition
um and it'd be interesting to see his
perspective on this
yeah what you said about projection so
that's like in the psychotherapy
it's like you're not seeing how it is
you're projecting you're you know you're
you're
um you're envisioning you're biased
you're projecting onto the world
you're projecting that emotions onto
them but it's like what if you start
from
hey it is a projection you are
in a projection you are the projection
your experience is the projection
of all these things that we're talking
about so it's like let's start from that
point of view that
you're not treating this person like a
robot you're assuming they're having
emotions
so you're engaged in this relational
projection that's intentional
about your relationship so how could we
connect for example
optimism about the relationship to how
you are going to map their facial
expression onto your behavior
not onto what they think but on how
you're going to act in a certain
situation
that's a pretty uh different context so
i think that's like
very uh interesting to bring the
psychological
projection the almost the
psychotherapeutic use of the term
to geometric progression uh and i'm
sorry geometric projection
and then connecting non-euclidean
geometric projections
to um general relativity
and to control theory and about systems
design all these different things
so just a few quotes that we can kind of
go through here
um basically this is just a summary of
what they believe the pcm's strengths
are
and how they summarize it which is that
the structure geometrically
of multimodal lived conscious experience
closely approximates a projective
three space so that's like a
three-dimensional space with kind of
this
geometer's lingo on which a projective
transformation i believe pgl4 is saying
it's a four-dimensional projection
projected down but we could hear from a
geometer with a little bit more
information here or what would the
physics community notate this as
our model fits intuitive data but it
also helps account for other phenomena
that might seem at first unconnected
including working perspectival
imagination inferences about the points
of view
and aims of others like the intentional
stance modulo
active inference and many peculiar
phenomena associated
with consciousness so obe out of body
experience chiatoscopy
derealization oceanic and mystical
experiences
it also sheds light on some visual
phenomena which we'll definitely
get to and it sounds like there's a
bunch of papes and they're probably
writing more
so if any of the authors want to you
know share what they're thinking or
doing now that's cool
here is an example we talked about a
little earlier which is that when we
consider
like think about the empire state
building we think about it
um in perspective like looking up at the
pers at the empire state building or
just floating away far away so that it
basically looks euclidean because it's
far away
but it's going to be both conceptualized
independently of any particular point of
view like you could zoom in in your
little brain
autocad simulator and imagine yourself
on the 40th floor
looking at a 90 degree angle in an
i-beam and you wouldn't have any
deception that it's actually euclidean
90 degrees but then at the same time we
can naturally
co-experience almost this like looking
up at it and understanding that no it's
still not going to look 90 degrees so
that's what optimally allows with this
projection
the perspectival accessing of euclidean
models of the world in memory for
appraisal and updating
of such models for active sampling so we
get to benefit from the sort of
statistical
uh uh reality realism let's say at least
not reality
of having a model that's actually
rectilinear for example
but then also have this total fluid
projection
that allows us to act and perspective
perspectively
understand yourself in that space so
there's the relative perception and then
there's that perspective
independent objective knowledge base
which doesn't mean it's correct it just
means that it's about an object
it's of an object it's not truth
objectivity it's objective like
it's about this box on my desk and
protective geometry helps functionally
connect subjectivity so being about the
subject that's relational
and then epistemic objectivity again not
truth just
knowledge about objects allowing us to
see consciousness as a kind of mediator
between the situated organism and the
objective world
it inhabits very cool stuff
they also write so active vision
thus becomes like a palpation of a 3d
spatial user surface to feel
the epistemic affordances that are
quantified by expected free energy
this anticipatory palpation with
temporal depth requires a generative
model that encompasses the consequences
of actions and their effective values
so in some other work by fristen and
colleagues where they've looked at for
example
reading and informational foraging with
the ocular motor with the eye muscles
and so the way that the eye scans around
the page it's not based upon
maximal reward it's based upon the
maximally informative
observation that could be made and what
is that observation
maximally informative in the framework
of well
top-down priors about semantics so when
somebody is coming towards you there's
like
subconscious isokaid movements that
first assess for example
the um broad category of person that it
belongs to and then they will zoom in on
different components of the face
and culturally informed areas of the
face that might signal different types
of things like
um whether there's going to be a good
relationship in the
future or not and so it is so
interesting what the authors did which
is to tie
this information foraging optimal
foraging info foraging
info thermodynamics perspective take it
from the cybernetics where it already
had been very well entrenched
and now say like that's our experience
of vision that's why even when your eyes
are secating
at the level that you're actually
perceiving it's actually a lot smoother
because our experience is sort of
smoothed out over those
underlying circades that being said
those cicadas are
driven in a top-down way as a compromise
with top-down forces let's say
by culturally informed priors your eyes
won't know how to scan if you don't know
how to read the language you won't know
which parts the letter are informative
which part's the word
but when you're fluent in the language
then we know that like all the letters
in the middle can be mixed up
because you're really just doing a
generative model of the text and that
turns out that it includes information
about font
and it includes sentence structure all
these other things you can't understand
the sentence with the words mixed up in
a different order
if the letters are in this in the right
order but the words are mixed the
semantics
don't allow the top down to inform the
bottom up
so your visual foraging is bunk because
you're going to be looking at the
difference between a b
and a d but you're not going to
understand what the sentence's
meaning is because that's the level
we're actually at
this framing of expected free energy
through projective transformation in
imagination
provides a method for envisioning how
things would look feel or be
from another hopefully better location
and thus guide action it's like
where would i be looking at if i were
figuring out what this word were
under my generative assumptions about
language
it is important to emphasize that
according to the projective
consciousness model
free energy minimization is always
operating as the fundamental algorithm
governing the field of consciousness and
thus there's never an end to the process
as there is never in practice a solution
that reduces free energy to zero
which because it's defined as this
informational distance against a
non-stationary uh
realism world uh it means that basically
it's always going to be bounded by zero
and this i thought was very funny hegel
might be happy to know that on the
projective consciousness model
consciousness is thus always somehow
unhappy even when it reaches the best
possible states available to it
so this is the uh well
known hegelian dialectic of thesis
antithesis
synthesis often shown as a loop as if it
were just this run around rock paper
scissor
here it's actually like a virtuous or a
vicious spiral
and it's just showing how this semantic
ordering of events
with thesis antithesis and synthesis
it's like
it never ends free energy minimization
optimization cybernetic control
processes multi-scale evolutionary
adaptive systems
they don't end they can't take a break
there can be relaxing
times but they can't rest in the actual
like stasis there can be stasis with
respect
to a certain dimension but that's
reflected by this seething activity
that actually structures the strange
attractor so that the system returns to
these homeostatic
preferred expected and optimal states
and if you prefer over evolutionary time
something that isn't
optimal or isn't functional you're not
going to exist
that model will not exist of the
statistical regularities in their niche
because their preferences the
observations they seek out will include
things like
toxins or jumping off of cliffs these
are not adaptive
observations uh interoceptively or from
a visual perspective
and so you end up not seeing models that
prefer those things and so it's like
this endless preference hunt
policy adaptive selection stuff
happening
um pretty cool stuff by the authors
any thoughts before we just look through
the figures before we close out
see you sash thank you so
just to spend a couple minutes on each
figure and just see what they kind of do
and then maybe we could either reach out
to the author or
just everybody who's listening to this
treat it as an open call
to come participate if you're curious
about this or
something does or doesn't add up let's
hear about it cool
so figure one is this account of
psychological phenomena
and i think it's almost like minecraft
helps us understand their simulation so
let's just imagine that they're doing
this in minecraft so and the a
is like the builders mode of minecraft
which ironically is still from a
perspective
even though they're trying their hardest
to represent the euclidean world it
turns out that can only be done
like the position of a camera wherever
that camera is there's no
location independent representation of
this euclidean space
unless they did like just a matrix they
said look just render it yourself but
when you rendered it
it would have to be from a perspective
you can't have all the perspectives at
once or flatten it in a dimension that
doesn't uh
work like that but then the lived space
s2 which is um they're using geometric
notation i'm not totally
sure about it maybe again a geometer
could come on but like basically what
they're saying is
even if you have this block of interest
when you put a person's head there or
they're
gener the locus of their generative
model um they're gonna see things in
this distorted way
b is the anti-space beyond the plane at
infinity
so i don't know exactly what it is but
it's it was interesting they said with a
transparent plane at infinity so it's
actually bringing this like transparent
uh notion back but this is like it's the
opposite
of what you see in some way i i guess
it's like it's the yeah it's everything
what you don't see it's like when you're
watching the sunset
what is not being seen and maybe is the
anti-space
and then this um god's eye projection
are like
somehow a transformation of the space
that
includes a lot of the planes of symmetry
they write
almost all the space is visible but
completely warped and the world model
manifested structures with complex
symmetries
so that's quite interesting because when
whether you agree with it being god's
eye or not i would say it's just another
projection of the system
um or just another at least as we're
seeing it but
maybe it's in like a ton of dimensions
or it has like other
trippy features but this is kind of like
highlighting just
the uh the the invariances of the visual
field
but that doesn't guide action like if
you're a baseball player and you're
running towards the ball
maybe there's like you know the one
symmetry would be all the grass when you
look down and all the blue sky when you
look up and then there's a ball and
that's like breaking the symmetry in
some very nuanced way in a dynamic way
but what do you want to actually see as
the ball comes towards you
well it's actually what we do see which
is that the ball gets bigger and
apparently more manipulatable
and we can do increased resolution on
things like its speed when it's further
away
that helps us um estimate where to go
but when it's close we can fine tune
so it's like exactly what you would want
as an embedded agent
is what we're experiencing and so we're
not experiencing this like
whoa it's just like hidden symmetries
nor are we experiencing
like the minecraft or the grand theft
auto
perspective where in our own embedded
situated experience relationally
engaging with affordances and the field
of consciousness and the field of
affordances are very related interesting
stuff great representations at very
least just stuff to think about and
learn
this one i thought was very informative
so this is a cue
um we can think of this visual illusion
as a cue
that's ambiguous so it's called the neck
or cube and basically depending on how
you see it
cough cough you can either see the
bigger wider side as like pointing up
into the left
which is left and right already our
relational spatial and
down and to the right so it's like you
know
which let's just let's just have a quick
show of hands raise your hand if
in looking at either of both of these
option one is gonna be i see it um
basically going up to the left two is
down at the right and three is it
switches for me
okay option one who sees it go up into
the left primarily
okay option two who sees it go down and
to the right primarily
and then who sees it just like rapidly
fluctuating
okay yeah i'd say
it seems like people raise their hand in
every category small sample size but yes
it's an illusion it's something that is
ambiguous and the reason why
is it's a three-dimensional cube at
least it suggests it hints
at being a three-dimensional cube but of
course it just lines on a page
okay we unpack that in a very generous
optimistic
way as being a two-dimensional drawing
of a cube if a child drew that you'd say
the child is trying to draw a cube
they're not
drawing like a logo with like you know a
double helix and two
you know it suggests a cube it hints at
a cube but it's a two-dimensional
projection onto a piece of paper well
duh
but it turns out that without shading
one of the sides or adding a light which
implies a perspective it's like you can
flip between these two solutions so to
speak of how to represent it
and so you in relation to this cube is
actually this ambiguity
that's being um flipped back and forth
between
and then specific um situations might
cause it to um prefer
one side or the other yeah lee what do
you think about that
well i think this i mean i'm really
interested in this because it kind of
relates to
um to the the point about unconscious
simulations
so if you're looking at it and it flips
which it can
which it can do and it does do if you
start to pay more attention to that you
you realize that
it doesn't just flip there's a sense in
which there's um there's a kind of an
unconscious doing which is
probably i'm assuming to do with the
predictions that you're making
so you know if i pay really close
attention what i notice is
that i'm isolating or tracing maybe
different portions of the
cube in different ways and then labeling
them in different ways so i kind of go
oh that's a you know
if this bits is a corner or that's the
front or that's the back
so and it's that that actually makes it
kind of shift
and i think it points to this idea you
know like that the you know the
perceptual world is is kind of a
co-construction
in a way but it's it's the it's that i
suppose what i'm interested in is that
it's a
it's a kind of a doing you know there's
a there's a way in which we're active in
it
which is more often than not transparent
you know we don't necessarily
say for example a more real world
example might be
um you know if we look at a tree we
might label it an object you know
typically we do
but um but actually it's kind of more of
a it's more of a process but we don't we
don't see it that way because we just
kind of you know we look at it and
you know for all intents and purposes if
it's not sailing because we wouldn't
notice that
but anyway yeah well no it's super
interesting
and the semantics and the illusion it's
like there's the old woman young woman
illusion um and then there's like the
bunny and the uh
duck and those the semantic level can be
like i'm looking at a bunny
and then you'll basically not see the
duck as much okay so the semantics can
inform us especially when you label for
action like this is the side with a
handle all of a sudden be like no i can
feel it dragging i'm only seeing now one
of those two sides fixed i'm keeping my
eyes
right where i want the handle to be and
all of a sudden it feels easier to keep
it in one
zone and then also it's like there's
illusions that are super ambiguous for
some people
and other people like i'm sorry i just
don't see the young woman in that
illusion i just don't see the bunny
i don't know what i i don't see that
dress as that color
remember that whole thing so that's like
because of the subconscious you know the
iceberg
of the actual neurophenomenology the
underpinnings and the mechanisms
some people are near a critical
transition point in their perception
where just by scanning their eyes the
ballerina will flip one way or the other
other people because of how their deep
priors guide their visual foraging and
their infogener
and their information foraging and their
by generation of model
they just will never be able to have the
ballerina switch directions neville
never be able to have the
duck go one way if you haven't seen a
duck you're not gonna see it in the back
of the head of a bunny
yeah steven yeah i saw an interesting
presentation by
lotto he does some work down in
neuroscience with
cirque du soleil actually and he showed
this
picture i think it was very similar
picture and he said that we mostly see
it from above
because we expect to see things from
above first
which i thought was kind of interesting
so there's kind of like
you do end up with this kind of inactive
situated
piece because it's like well i'm sucking
something here i'm probably looking from
above if i'm looking for above
these things pop out and then well maybe
it's um
so you know i thought that was kind of
interesting that reminds me of
children's cereal
being put lower on the aisle to get them
in their zone of affordances it's in
their proximal zone so you can do niche
based partitioning
of surveillance capitalism great i love
it
and then also uh there's a lot of other
uh natural
situations where we can track what an
animal looks at and yeah they're looking
at things that are actionable
and that's like us grabbing something
from the top there's not maybe foraging
for branches
you don't visualize it from the top but
that's something that we can't do
but really we specialize in picking up
things that were above okay let's look
at just this last
two figures so figure three i think is
uh related to this
uh paper 2018 paper that they mentioned
in the very end
for more details on this family of
simulations but
essentially it's showing like multiple
views
of the expectation map and the prior
belief map and
basically an agent has to move from the
left side to the right side
so like it moves from here's it's left
here it's starting and it has to move
through his pit
i don't know if that's a bad state or
what about it but basically here it is
blue
it believes there's a goal over here
it's going to pierce into this darker
blue with its zone of proximal awareness
essentially
move through the pit resolve uncertainty
about what actions to take
here the action path is simple she keep
walking in a straight line
um even though it looks like narrow and
then
finally it gets in contact with the goal
state purple
and so from its local geometrically uh
distorted point of view projected point
of view there's a free energy
thermometer
and it's like first it scans around and
then it's like okay
i'm gonna go that way towards the goal
and reduce my uncertainty and then it's
just getting lit up
and that's interestingly where dopamine
comes into play it's something i would
love to talk about
soon because i've worked on dopamine the
free energy principle perspective
dopamine is usually thought about as a
reward molecule oh it makes you happy or
it's the reward you know slot machines
and all that
but if we think about it in this context
dopamine firing patterns
in this phase anticipatory of the reward
actually have to do with free energy and
um when you get to the reward your
precision is confirmed because you
already believed there was a reward
there
so actually and this is shown in figure
as you approach the max zone of maximal
information uncertainty reduction
that's when the free energy is getting
out of control
so to speak and then when the goal is
achieved precision is achieved again
so when we think about what the
neurophysiology actually is
and how different interventions in our
neurophysiology might map on
to differences in what about somebody
who doesn't have motivation
even though they know the goal is right
here but they're just not
even if they can see there and other
people say it's well lit you can just do
it
and they just don't have the motivation
maybe someone else is here and they go
actually i like the other side
more or all these different things
without passing judgment on what these
states are what level of analysis or
what culture says they're rewarded or
not just how can we map some of these
cybernetic parameters onto the neuro
and eventually the phenomenological
parameters
and i think figure four gets out a lot
of similar
ideas because it's talking about this
relationship between the lived
space and the peripersonal space one
might almost be able to save
and also events that are perceived or
imagined
and that surprisal and then reduction of
uncertainty
this sort of realignment reordering of
either action
or the inference side to reduce surprise
about the world given this very deep
generative model
um that's kind of where it's at and
those were some really cool ideas
brought up in the paper
and just if anyone else wants to raise
their hand just a few more interesting
notes on this
figure i thought were cool they show a
loop from um
prediction to the uh perception to
prediction of the change in free energy
imagination and then action and so we've
been talking a lot about cycles that go
like perception
action world right perception agent
action world like that but here this is
a loop that happens
in an organism or in a model of analysis
still it's a nested markov situation and
it doesn't replace the other one it's
not the other one the other one is about
agents in the world
and this is actually like saying in
these reflexive conscious
systems what is actually the loop
that allows imaginated imaginated events
to influence action so i don't know if
this is and it shows which directions
different things can influence
each other here it has perception and
action influencing each other so maybe
that's the
other world in the agent loop but then
here's these other processes playing out
just very
cool and then here's like the vector of
time on a free energy landscape
through time and it's projected and it's
going downhill
so to speak through time in this like
vector weird way
and as i understand it and i barely
understand it that's where the math
and the research is is it's like okay
chemical reactions always go downhill
well a candle burning is still downhill
okay what about
a cell well a cell is also downhill in a
really
specific way well all of our policy
actions are downhill
in what landscape that's the free energy
optimization
how is the landscape changing that's a
relationship of how our meta
optimization proceeds
amidst different kinds of environmental
regularities
so um yeah that's all
i would say about these figures before
we close anyone else have any
last thoughts what would be something to
go into more in 9.2
yep let's do um alex and then stephen uh
i'll try to be brief um uh it's
interesting to me
like relating this to the interview
principle that
if you model these dynamic systems as
agents which are trying to
uh export energy from their
identity um uh
by performing action and greater systems
that they're a part of
their action actually creates new
unknowns that they have to perceive and
solve
and maybe cognition is just the boundary
between
direct feedback and the larger
environment they are a part of
like maybe it is the self-referential
like structure that necessarily creates
itself
i don't know cool awesome thoughts
steven
yeah well just thanks for unpacking
these diagrams because i had looked at
this paper a fair bit
once in the past but some of this stuff
was really hard to
so this is this is really helpful um i i
think this idea of
the that there is this imagination
that's going on is really useful i i
think
i don't know how many other papers
really deal with this so i think that's
quite
quite interesting and one bit in the
paper that we might want to think about
that i did notice is this
this it does say in the paper something
about how this doesn't try and deal with
all the subconscious dynamics
underneath but that it's about trying to
find this kind of
extra layer of conscious imagination
or projection so it might be interesting
just to
explore that next time cool
thanks for the suggestion and everyone
thanks a lot for participating
we will have follow-up forms for the
participants it's in your
calendar invite and uh via that
mechanism for the live participants or
just a
twitter youtube comment for anyone else
please provide us with feedback
suggestions
questions we'll be able to go into them
for 9.2
good groundwork today and then yeah 9.2
we'll be able to talk a lot more
hopefully hear from a bunch of different
perspectives um
and just stay in communication with team
com
it was a great discussion really thanks
everyone for participating it's just
like super
fascinating stuff so thanks again for
the conversation
and we will talk next week everybody
who's hearing it you're welcome to join
next week or the following week
but thanks again everybody and we'll see
you later